The next step takes us from S3 to SF.
Then we get reward R3 when that happens.
The first thing that happens is we
update the eligibility for that state.
Then, we compute this quantity that
we're going to add to all the state
updates.
This gives us R3 plus gamma times
the previous value of the state
that we just ended up in minus
the state that we came from.
And this update is going to
get applied to all the states,
proportional to their eligibility.
So, we can do that same thing again,
just add this quantity into
all these things and simplify.
Does that sound okay?
>> It does sound okay and I think
I finally see where this is going.
So, if you look at the pseudo code
right, you say for all s, and
you update the value of the state,
if you look at the stuff that's
multiplied by alpha sub T,
all that is basically is your error.
Right?
[CROSSTALK]
>> Right, that's why this
is TD learning.
>> Right, it's what you thought it was.
The difference between what
you thought it was and
what it turned out to be when you
actually saw the reward if you assume
that your future guess is
about the values are right.
>> Exactly.
>> So, because of that cute little
compactify telescoping thing that
you just did, I think without
actually writing everything out,
I can guess what the next
values are going to look like.
So, and tell me if I'm right.
The delta for VT of S1 is basically
going to have seen one more thing.
So, it'll end up being R1 plus
gamma R2 plus gamma squared R3.
>> And where does that come from?
>> Well, that comes from the term
that you just added over there.
>> The R3 and
the eligibility for state S1.
>> Right, which you've managed
to make the gamma squared.
So, the eligibility isn't just
whether you've seen a state before.
It's actually keeping track of
how long ago you saw that state.
>> Good.
>> Right and so, if there was another
state after SF and we kept going, we'd
see it get that would become gamma cube,
then S2 would become gamma squared,
and S3 would become gamma,
and so on and so forth.
That's quite clever.
Okay, so you would see R1 plus gamma R2
plus gamma squared R3 plus
gamma cubed (VT-1(S4)).
>> Well,
there is no S4 to the final state.
>> I'm sorry, SF, thank you,
thank you very much.
SF minus (VT-1(S1)), so that stays.
In all that is is the error,
it's what you're guess was of the value.
And what you actually ended up seeing,
which was all the rewards that you saw
plus whatever future value
there's going to be.
>> Good.
All right, we may have done
a little too much jumping.
So, can I fill that in with the way
that you just described it?
>> Okay.
So, some frustrating amount of
algebra and rewriting later,
it seems to have fallen
into this pattern and
this is what you're talking about,
right Charles?
>> Yeah,
that's exactly what I was thinking.
>> So, we have this sort of
temporal difference thing.
So, we can now state a claim which just
follows very clearly from the example.
And that is that this update, this
TD(1) update that we just talked about,
actually does the same thing as the
outcome-based update, which is to say,
we wait to see what all the rewards,
the discounted rewards,
are on the entire trajectory, and
then we just update our prediction for
the state that they started
from with those rewards.
Keep in mind that these things are zero.
The VT minus one of SF is zero,
so this kind of goes away, and
this kind of goes away, and this kind of
goes away and we're really just talking
about the discounted sum of
rewards minus the old prediction.
The discounted sum of rewards
minus the old prediction.
So, at least in the case where
there is no repeated states,
we visit a state more than
once along a trajectory.
Everything beautifully cancels and
what you get is exactly the same update.
The TD(1) update is exactly
the same update as just waiting for
the outcomes and updating based on that.
>> That's actually really impressive.